all right what is rally road and why did
you build it well Riley Road is an
investment where we take high value
appreciating assets and turn them into
stocks and we built it based on missed
opportunities honestly so myself and my
co-founders always felt excited by
alternative assets and different types
of investing and more comfortable in
those places rather than in areas where
let's say it's the the deck is sort of
stacked against you okay
traditional equities etc I don't think
it's hard to be the smartest person in
the room when you've got people studying
it for a living day and night so
analysts are studying Netflix exactly
they're in touch with the management
there that's right they have all kinds
of proprietary data sets that are you
can tap you can know if like Netflix
apps are being downloaded or maybe they
have VPN data that shows the utilization
of Hulu versus actually Netflix versus
resources right so they have all this
inside information that's right and then
comparative by comparison in alternative
assets like collectible cars was the one
that I was excited about and music for
example art collectibles things that my
co-founders were excited about we we
found that the information spectrum is
actually quite flat what really is
missing is access and that's something
that you could solve for with great
financial and regulatory technology all
right and that is a big piece of this so
you've started off doing collectible
cars yes how many cars have you done
funds for is it would be a fun structure
it's not a fun structure so it's
actually it's really it we try to make
it as close to the stock market as
possible so each deal is its own equity
and each car has its own security that
is backed by that particular asset ok oh
it's an IPO it's an IPO and it's not
traded on the public market it is not
exchange-traded but it is traded on a
secondary market that's access through
the app got it yes so take us through
one of these car deals sure and maybe
maybe we should we show the app is that
your best way to do it yeah so I
download this app rally Road I decide I
want to invest in cars yep and Here I am
you've opened the app I'll sports casted
a little bit beautiful looking there's a
94 Lamborghini Diablo which was by the
way one of the coolest cars in the
history
of supercars agreed completely Diablo is
gorgeous but I don't know if that's a
classic yet it's a 94 mm 4 mm 14 +5 it's
a 25 year old car which I think means it
hits the classic designation at 20 about
right yeah it depends on that it depends
on the country but yes here for sure so
the United States 20s a classic 35 25
classic yep and then what 40s antique
technically but 40 now means like the
1975 Corvette or Mustang which were
terrible so I'm it depends on the
decades and a lot of this stuff is
coming back around right that's where
you know you start to get people who get
older who find it exciting and a lot of
the design trends you see it doesn't
just happen to it with collector cars
but it comes in literally app design and
it comes in fashion and it comes in all
the different aspects of what you're
seeing across code anyway just back to
the classic car example yes the 60s
muscle cars which were classic cars to
us yep are they now consider antiques I
don't believe so there's still classic
cars yeah a lot of Peaks me pre-war I
think people think of it more that way a
Model T whatever exactly so the classics
are the sixties yeah what do they call
the 80s and 90s cars then Oh some people
call them young timers young time yeah
it's like a german word that people are
using for them
young timers like hey you and or
something us that's a good jargon watch
it is it is we're doing jargon watching
all the inside newsletter so I'm gonna
put that in inside waters and timers and
we don't we don't discriminate by any
sort of error what we like to find are
assets that bridge the gap between
generations all right so a 94 Diablo
this is yes that when it was new was
$175,000 car at the time ballpark this
one is a little bit more this is a
really special version this is the 30th
anniversary version and it also is one
of 28 with what they call the Yoda kit
which is basically this is the
competitor to the f40 from Ferrari oh
this is the the best of the best and
it's in the right colors so two hundred
thousand it's in great shape and you
guys are now buying it for five hundred
ninety-eight thousand correct that's
what it's worth in the market that's the
market cap of this company right now
that owns this and the single asset got
it so now how you say what I explore
this dyrdek the Explorer button
happens now so now we walk you through
the story of this and we really tried to
build a storytelling type app with a
transaction attached to it less than a
stock trading app right understand we
didn't want to go over anybody's head we
wanted to give them the ability to dig
as deep as they wanted to infringe
individual asset you have a slider here
it's a beautiful purple Lamborghini it
is and it says here these are terrible
asset right so these are all the public
transactions for other ac30
your cars that have transacted in the
public markets got it it says 1 million
3 million million one or that's one
month three months ago six months and so
here's it you know here's an asset
transaction at arm Sotheby's auction
right for seven hundred sixty one
thousand here's another one a listing
that's recently up so we try and we're
scrolling through all of these all of it
so that's right and so we try to give as
much information as we can in cars where
this twenty eight of them in the world
you don't get too many data points but
in other ones we're like a 63
split-window which we have in here
there's hundreds and we're afraid to
split-window Corvette exactly which had
the rear window exactly instead of one
windshield they put two in a bar across
the back you got beautiful Corvette okay
next so then we try to sort of
contextualize the opportunity and give
people some people put a big disco fever
the only prescription is this car inside
hook of course inside hook is that like
some press or it's impressed yeah so it
depends on the individual and we tell it
not join the conversations we have a
sort of a chat stream that will be
developed around oh yeah pastors can
talk about say we're overpaying we're
underpaying whatever they you you got a
knack whatever then we walk you through
the investment thesis fairly quickly so
you can get guidance for it twenty-eight
of the SE thirty Diablos reside in the
US since new number forty-three LD is
one of twenty-eight Jodha cars produce
its low mileage and highly original
example of one ulemas most exotic
supercars got it and if you want to dig
in all the details on this individual
vehicle which is like mile a mile
opening numbers owners etc everything
you want you do all that work to make
sure it's matching numbers in vet it yes
completely and we put our own we put our
own money into every single deal okay
that's good to all common shares between
two and ten percent of every deal we buy
ourselves which is it aligns incentives
and make sure we're is responsible to
every deal we bring out but that is to
you know for our community